Is your problem that God sent spirits to
do something evil? Is that what you're
saying?
>> Yes.
>> Let me ask you this. Is magic evil?
>> Who created magic?
>> God created magic.
>> So Allah brought in evil into existence.
>> Uh so yes, per se. Yes.
>> Is it a good thing to teach evil or is
it an evil thing to teach evil?
>> It is an evil thing to teach evil.
>> Thank you. So Allah sent angels down to
do an evil thing,
>> right?
>> How are you doing?
>> What's up, man? I'm good. How are you?
>> Good.
>> You said I I'll convert to Islam if I
change your mind, right?
>> Yes.
>> Uh what what is a lying spirit?
>> What is a lying spirit?
Yes,
>> Jabriel.
>> A lying. Lying.
>> Yeah, Jabel. Jabel lied to Muhammad.
>> No, like what is a lying spirit to you,
>> Jabriel?
>> Like what is a Because the Bible uses a
lying spirit. It says a lying spirit. I
don't understand what it means. A lying
spirit. It means a jabil.
>> That means the devil a demon or what?
>> It means a gabriel. Something like
gabriel. So like imagine imagine
[clears throat]
imagine a cave and a spirit comes and
tells somebody who cannot read to read.
Right? And then telling them I I I'm I'm
from your Lord or I'm from your Lord.
Right? That's that's a lying spirit
because the Lord didn't send that.
>> Okay. Okay. So, can you go to first
kings
first kings 22:22?
>> Would you like to know what you have to
change my mind on for me to consider
Islam? Cuz this has nothing to do
>> uh because I'm trying to prove like uh
you your religion is false from that
from that verse. That's what I'm trying
to do. I'm trying to change it first.
>> How does that prove Islam though?
>> How does it prove Islam? If you go
there, it says, "Your Lord sent a lying
spirit to the prophets of the king of
Israel to make them lie." That means
your your that means God sent a devil to
go lie to the king of Israel. That's
what it says in the first Kings 20:22.
Hm. And you're saying that because God
sent lying spirits and these lying
spirits, these false prophets lied due
to these lying spirits that therefore
>> God is not
>> No, no, I'm not saying that. I'm saying
why did he send a lying spirit to make
the false prophets lie?
>> They were already lying. This is his
punishment on them. So like are you
saying that this proves that that like
the God of the Bible is false or
something?
>> Okay.
I'm trying I'm trying to Is there a Is
there a problem with this, bro? Is my
question. Is there a problem with this?
>> Yes. There there is there is a big
problem. Cuz
>> what's the problem?
>> Cuz he sent a demon.
>> He sent a demon to make them lie.
>> It doesn't say that.
>> Go there. Go first Kings 20 22 22.
>> It doesn't say he sent a demon.
>> It says he sent a demon.
>> He It says a lying spirit.
>> Okay. So So it doesn't say a demon,
right? It doesn't say demon, right?
What is a lying spirit? What is the
definition of a lying spirit?
>> Just just just follow with me for a
second so that we can get somewhere.
>> Can we agree that the verse does not say
demon?
>> It doesn't say demon. Yes,
>> I got you. Okay. Is there a problem with
God sending lying spirits to false
prophets who are already lying as his
judgment upon them?
Why would Okay, my question for that
would be why would he send a line?
>> I just I just need an answer. I just
told you. Uh so just answer the
question.
>> Yes, there is a problem.
>> There's a problem.
>> And and Okay. And what's the what
exactly is the problem? [clears throat]
>> The problem is he sent a lying spirit
instead of a pure spirit to go deal with
the false prophets.
>> Got it. So why why is God wrong for
doing that?
>> Okay. So your God uh God said in that
verse said oh go ahead and entice the
king. That what is entice? The meaning
of entice.
>> I'm not I'm not hearing I'm not hearing
what's brother. I'm not hearing the pro.
You don't have to repeat the the story
to me. I know the story. What is the
problem?
>> Yeah.
The problem is he sent a lying spirit
instead of a holy spirit.
>> Why is that a problem?
>> Why would he send a Why wouldn't he send
an angel instead of a lying spirit?
>> Cuz he didn't want cuz he cuz he didn't
want to. He wanted to judge them by
using a lying spirit.
>> Is he the lying spirit said
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Because the lion spirit came to God
and he said, "Hey, I can go do this for
you." And God said, "Yo, go ahead. Go
lie to them."
>> Mama, I'm giving you I'm giving you a
chance right now.
>> Stop repeating the story and tell me
what the problem is.
>> What's the problem?
>> The problem is Okay. The problem is
either your you the god you follow is a
demon or a devil. Why? make a cuz cuz
the the the false prophets weren't
lying. That means the false prophets
weren't lying because
>> the lying sp Let me let me just do this
uh to try to break it down a little a
little better.
>> Is your problem that
God sent spirits
uh and it seems like to do like to to do
something evil? Is that what you're
saying?
Yes. He sent a lying spirit to do
something evil,
>> right? And so God sending someone to do
evil
is wrong for God on God. Is that right?
>> Yes, it it is wrong cuz he came to God
to give to give him that permission to
do that.
>> Okay, I got you.
>> Give him the permission.
>> All right, you got me. You know what? I
think that you made a good argument. You
know what?
>> If you Let me finish my point. If You
already did, man.
I got you.
>> You don't understand the fool.
>> I do. I Look, all I
>> All I needed to know was what your
problem was. Now that I see what your
problem is, I'm saying you're making a
good point.
>> No, no, that's that's not my only
problem. My second problem.
>> I don't I don't need I don't Brother
brother, I don't need you to give me
another problem. Let's do it with one at
a time. Let's deal with this first
problem.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> And then we can go to your second one.
Okay. So this first problem,
>> God sends
someone or a spirit, a lying spirit,
whatever it is, permits them to lie to
prophets or do some type of evil action.
And therefore, God is then evil is your
is your logic, right? Okay.
>> God, your God is the devil or evil evil
God.
>> I got you. I got you. I like how you
talk, man. You talk with very a lot of
confidence, man. I like that conviction.
Let me ask you this. Um, is magic evil?
>> Magic. Magic. Yes. Yes, it is.
>> Yeah, magic is evil.
>> Yes.
Allah. Yes.
>> Okay. Awesome. So, magic is evil. Okay.
Um, who created magic?
>> Who created magic? God created magic.
>> Yes. God brought it into existence. So
Allah brought in evil into existence.
>> No. Uh so Allah I know the story you're
talking about. Allah Allah did that to
test the people. He says he do not
>> He did what? He did what?
>> He did it he did he he sent a angel to
teach them to teach them magic.
>> Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa. There's
instruction.
>> Wait. Allah sent angels to teach evil.
Uh
can can I finish my point? I just want
to I just finish what I want.
>> I don't want to know cuz I'm I'm a
little lost.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh okay. Okay. Okay. I'm I'm going to
make it simpler for you. God send a
angel to teach them something evil. But
God also made instructions. He says,
>> "No, no, wait. God also says, "Hey,
>> God God was testing them." God said,
"Hey,
>> so God was testing them with evil.
>> You will not."
>> Yes. Per se. Yes.
>> So God sent the angels instructions.
>> I got you. Wait, just let's break this
down.
>> Allah,
>> if you don't let me finish, you won't
understand.
>> Well, I I'm just I'm trying to I'm
trying to show you how I understand
somebody. I ask questions. Okay. So,
>> okay. Allah sends the angels
to go down to teach mankind the evil
work of magic. He teaches he sent them
down to teach them evil magic, right? To
test them.
>> Yeah. Got it. Yes. With an instruction.
There is an instruction.
>> I got you. So Allah
sent people to Now let me ask you this.
If you teach someone evil, if you're
teaching evil, are you evil? Is that an
is it evil to teach evil?
>> Okay. Okay. So, first of all, when the
angels came there, they came with an
instruction.
>> If you can answer that question,
brother, I would I would love if you can
answer that question. Is it a is it
good? Okay. Is it good to teach evil or
is it evil to teach evil?
>> You I will tell you why you won't let me
finish. cuz you just want to like have a
clip. I don't know. But
>> try if you don't let me see.
>> I I already got like 10 clips out of
this. Trust me.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, he sent them down
with an instruction. He said, "Whoever
learns this, they will go to hellfire."
God already told them that. God made in.
>> No, it doesn't. It doesn't say whoever
learns this. It doesn't say It doesn't
say whoever learns this. It says if you
do it, if you practice it,
>> go to the verse.
>> So, now Yeah. Okay, I got you. But hold
on. Before I go to the verse, I want you
to calm down and answer my question. Is
it a good thing to teach evil or is it
evil to teach evil?
>> I told you is a test. It was a test.
>> I didn't ask if Okay. You know what? You
know what? You know that that would be
an answer to my question if I asked was
was it a test
that was it a test?
Yeah, it was a test. That's an answer to
that question. But unfortunately, I
didn't ask that. So, I'm gonna give you
the question one last time.
Is it a good thing to teach evil or is
it an evil thing to teach evil? Which
one is it?
>> Is it an evil thing from your
perspective? Is evil [laughter]
per adventure. Habibi per adventure.
>> Okay.
>> P per adventure. Hab BB per adventure.
Hold
your horses. I didn't
>> I still haven't let me finish my first
point.
>> I can hear the smile on your face.
You're having a good time. I like that,
brother.
>> Nah, cuz cuz you're not letting me
finish my first point. You didn't let me
finish my first point.
>> I let you finish everything. I let you
finish everything. Now we're on this.
>> You didn't let me finish my Oh, I did
from that.
>> So So I'll ask it again, brother.
Brother, I'll ask it again.
Don't you dare come and say from my
perspective. Don't do that. Don't play
with me. Okay.
We got We got a lot of people watching.
Don't play Don't play with them.
>> You want me to say my God is evil.
That's what I
>> I don't I only want you to just tell the
truth, man. I And that the truth.
>> Okay.
>> Hey, that the truth. That the truth,
man.
>> No problem.
>> All right. So, I'll ask it again. Give
me an honest answer. Is it a good thing
to teach evil or is it an evil thing to
teach evil?
>> Uh is it is an evil thing to teach evil?
>> Thank you. So Allah sent angels down to
do an evil thing, right?
>> Um nope, he didn't. He didn't.
[laughter]
is funny. He didn't send them to do an
evil thing because it's a [laughter]
test is a test for the people. Whoever
does this is a instructions. He says
whoever does this, they go to hellfire.
[laughter]
It's just it's just who who who
who's doing it. It's just that God is
made it very clear.
>> Hey, look. I I got you. I hear you. I
hear you. Um did you did you finish your
football?
>> Can I finish my second point now?
>> No. No. We're We're still on the first.
I finish my second point.
>> We're We're still in the first one. So,
just to be clear,
>> okay, no problem.
>> Teaching magic is evil, you said, right?
>> Yes.
>> And the angels taught the human beings
uh magic, which is evil, right?
>> Okay. Wait, wait, wait a minute though.
Wait a minute.
>> Answer, please.
>> Wait. Okay. Okay. Wait a minute.
>> Answer.
>> Wait a minute.
>> Okay. Okay. Yes. Thank you. And to teach
evil
is an evil thing, right?
>> Yes.
To teach evil is an evil thing.
>> So to teach magic, which is evil, is
evil. The angels were sent to teach
magic, an evil thing, and them teaching
the magic is an evil thing for them to
do. And the one and they're sent by
Allah. So Allah sent the angels to do an
evil thing, right? Which is teach magic.
Correct.
>> Okay. Okay. So
>> correct.
>> Please, please, I need this answer. Yes.
Okay. So Allah sent the angels to do an
evil thing. So therefore, Allah is the
devil. He's a demon. He's evil. And you
should leave Islam. Right.
>> Okay. So you made your point. Let me
make
>> Answer this question.
>> Let me make my point. answer this
question.
>> Okay, let me Okay, let me make my point
in that question.
>> Yeah. Okay, good. So, so what you need
to do is answer the question and then
expound if you want.
>> Okay. Uh I'mma answer the question. That
doesn't make Allah the devil or evil.
>> Thank you. Okay, I got it. That's all I
needed. That's all I needed because
watch what I showed you. I did all of
this and it was fun doing it. I'm glad
you were here.
>> You don't let me finish though. You
don't brother.
>> You finished, brother.
>> You like to talk,
>> brother. You're finished. You're
finished. Well, let me show you before
before I let you go.
>> You like to be ignorant.
>> Before I got I got you. I got you. I'm
Before I let you go, I'm going to tell
you what happened cuz I guarantee you
you don't know what happened. I'm going
to tell you what happened.
>> I know what happened. I know what
happened. I
>> You brought me an argument.
>> You said more than me.
>> You said it was just a question.
>> Hey, uh you know what? Let me let me let
me let one of my colleagues answer this.
He was a Muslim. One of my colleagues
said this once.
He He hates me, by the way. But I'mma
play it for you. I'mma play it on full
volume.
Listen to this.
>> Know he knows more about Islam than you.
And in this room, in this room, a lot of
people in the whole world. Every knows
more things about Islam than me. And
then you than a lot of people in this
room. A lot of people in the whole
world. Every knows more about
>> about Islam than me. And then you than a
lot of people in this room. A lot of
people in the whole world. Every knows
more things about Islam than me. And
then you than a lot of people in this
room. A lot of people in the whole
world.
Now that my friend was a Muslim.
I was a Muslim saying that. So according
to according to a Muslim, I know more
about Islam than you.
That's a that's that that was a Muslim
on the Muslim panel. They were they were
having they they were having a surviving
God logic episode pre preseason episode
and
you will I I believe that I believe that
you're you're a smart guy. So let's
break down what happened. Muhammad, you
brought an argument against Yahweh,
against the God of the Bible, saying
that he sent Hold on. Let me hold on,
brother. Slow down, man. I've been
patient with you.
He saying that he sent he sent down
angel or uh lying spirits to lie of
false prophets. So therefore, he sent an
evil spirit to do an evil thing. And
therefore, God of the Bible is evil and
demonic. Oh, sorry guys. Thank you.
>> I'm I'mma tell you why it's different.
I'm going tell you why is it different.
>> Wait, hold on. Let me let me finish.
>> So,
>> okay.
>> Once I got your Once I got your your
what your problem was, I found your
standard and I brought it back to you.
Put it back in your face. Yay.
He's the devil. He's evil because he
sent lying spirits as a judgment on
false prophets which caused them to lie
even more. Right? So Allah
>> false prophets
>> Allah hold on a sec. Hold on a second.
Allah Allah sent angels
to teach magic which is evil. Sent them
for the purpose of teaching magic which
teaching magic is an evil thing. So
therefore, according to your standard,
Allah is Satan, the devil, a demonic uh
joke for sending angels to do an e. See,
he didn't even send he didn't send
demons. Allah sent pure angels to teach
evil.
>> Wow.
>> Okay. Okay.
That's crazy. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, can
I finish my point on that on that verse?
Can I finish my point in that verse? I
will tell you why is it different.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> I'mma tell you why.
>> Go ahead.
>> The different
>> Go ahead and tell me why it's different.
>> Go ahead, man.
Go ahead. Tell me why it's different.
[clears throat]
[snorts]
Go ahead.
Go ahead. Tell Go on and tell me. I like
when my food talk back to me.
[clears throat]
I like when my food talk right back to
me.
Get off my stage, man. You did good
though, man. You did good. You You can
survive. You can survive logic any day.
You You can survive logic any day. I
appreciate this video. I do. I
appreciate it. [snorts]
I appreciate